we're going to begin this hour with news
we hope that we would never have to
report to you the death toll from the
covet 19 pandemic has now reached 1
million americans that's according to
the white house president biden will
mark that very sad milestone later today
experts think that the real number is
really much higher and it continues to
grow our lead national correspondent
that would be david beck now has shared
the stories of many of the families
dealing with the laws those who cannot
move on so easily david checked in to
see how they're doing now with the
passage of time
over the past two and a half years we
have interviewed someone from almost
every state in the country who's been
affected by kovid's death grip it's hard
to breathe for him we've told stories of
hundreds of people but we don't often
take the opportunity to circle back and
say
how you doing now
that's what this is about
pamela orlando was a registered nurse
from new jersey and a single mom to two
boys
i remember one of her sons telling me
you know david mom recorded videos of
her downward spiral because she wanted
people to see what the virus was doing
to her i feel horrible
pam died on april 16 2020.
she was only 56.
we checked in on her two sons
her eldest reid had considered a career
in broadcasting but after his mother
died he started working for a medical
staffing company he says
as a way to honor her pam's youngest son
ryan is an 18 year old high school
senior he told us he has dedicated his
studies to his mom and recently he
received a scholarship to go to college
we remember cody lister at one time he
was the youngest person to die of covet
in the state of colorado cody was an
avid baseball player and just an
all-around great athlete
he was 21 when kovitt killed him his
father kevin also fought covet but he
and his wife survived the virus
cody's dad and mom tell us they try and
live lives that would make him proud
they talk to him every day
and share with them the milestones that
he's missed
their new akita puppy his sister
sierra's first prom
she actually plays softball and even
wears her brother's number 13.
[Music]
32 year old jonathan coelho he passed
away on april 22 2020 after 27 days in
the hospital
just a few hours before they placed him
on a ventilator he wrote a note to his
wife katie and she shared it with us
in it he said
it makes me so proud to be your husband
and the father to braden and penny you
could see from start to finish my
husband worshipped us
almost two years later katie tells us
that parenting alone has been a real
challenge especially while grieving but
it is her desire to be strong for their
two children that's what's driving her
forward
she says they have been her brightest
lights since jonathan's death
braden who has cerebral palsy learned to
walk with the aid of a walker but he's
doing it all by himself
penny took her first steps come on
on father's day last year good job
[Laughter]
i remember 33 year old angel moseley
of new orleans now hers was a
breakthrough case of covid she actually
contracted the disease and died despite
being fully vaccinated angel was
hospitalized on a friday
she died two days later july 25th 2021
we flew down to new orleans shortly
after she passed away and sat with her
mother at the family's church if she
were here right now what would she want
you to say
keep our business going because that was
her baby that was her dream
i am happy to report to you that
angelle's legacy not only lives on
but her request is being honored that's
a beautiful color on gel's clothing
store the brave boutique which
specializes in plus size clothing for
women is still open and it's being run
by her mom
and her friends
just two hours west of new orleans is
where david lemare lived in lafayette
he had just graduated from high school
when he died due to covet he and his
brother jacob were actually both
hospitalized in the same icu with covet
19 related pneumonia
the brother survived david fought for
weeks their father mark who is a doctor
spent so many days by david's bedside
praying
and watching his son's slow
deterioration i learned a lot about my
son
about how compassionate he was and how
deep his faith was david died july 31st
2020
his loved ones commemorated his passing
with a balloon release one year later
david had a love of photography
especially landscapes
his dad told us that whenever he sees a
sunset it gives him a good feeling that
his son is watching over them
alfredo and susanna pavitau of new
jersey were married for 44 years they
both contracted covid and they died
within four days of each other back in
march 2020. now they had been on kovit's
front lines she was a nurse he was a
medical transporter
by
their
daughter
gets harder for me we checked in on
cheryl and she told us that osha
investigated the hospital where her
parents died accusing the hospital of
failing to protect employees from
exposure to coronavirus now cheryl had
had concerns that her father was not
provided with the proper ppe nor was he
trained on how to use it
cheryl tells us after all of this she
has become a certified health inspector
and
she wants to be an osha investigator
herself
finally she told us it was her mother's
wish that she would find love
she has
meet uber
i believe my husband was sent to me from
my parents she told us
[Music]
you probably have noticed the chairs
that i'm surrounded by
they are empty
and that is meant to honor those who we
didn't name
those whose names and stories
may never be known publicly
may their memories be a blessing
david we certainly did notice the chairs
and we all thought that's exactly what
you were doing i remember when we used
to do these stories once a week we'd go
through and remember that remember the
people that did not survive it just it's
a reminder again guys about cova that it
it doesn't care about your age your race
your gender and i think it's so
important we keep throwing around this
number one million people as you've
shown us be fine those one million
people are real names of people who were
loved and dearly missed as we said they
have stories yes i'll never forget it's
so hard to wrap your head around that a
number of that size and david i mean i
commend you for doing such a tremendous
job in helping us engage with those
stories as representative of that bigger
number and then the empty chairs is just
such a powerful metaphor for what this
country has lost
tony i just want to say to them to the
families we've spoken to thank you for
allowing us to tell your stories and to
those we haven't
we are thinking of you this morning this
was a tribute to all of you
exactly right and i think we need to
keep reminding people this is what kova
does it tears people apart and leaves
behind tremendous tremendous pain for
sure david thank you very much
you better